معنا من القدس ايهاب جبارين الكاتب المختص
بالشؤون الاسرائيليه اهلا بك سيد جبارين
في الوقت اذا الذي يزور فيه بلينكن
اسرائيل وهذه المره الخامسه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر وهو يردد تكرارا بانه لا يريد
توسعه نطاق الحرب في نفس اليوم تغتال
اسرائيل قائد ميداني بارز في حزب الله كيف
يمكن فهم
ذلك نعم تحياتي وسله مساء الخير يعني
بطبيعه الحال هنالك الكثير من الاشارات في
هذا المضمار تحديدا يعني في الداخل
الاسرائيل الكل يعلم بان بنيامين نتنياهو
يدير حربا واحده هي حربه وصراع البقاء لا
اي شيء اخر هذا يدركه في كل المضامين وفي
كل المفاهيم بل اكثر من ذلك يعني حتى ان
كان هنالك نوع من التقاطع والاتفاق ما بين
المستوى السياسي المتمثل ببنيامين نتنياهو
وما بين المستوى العسكري والامني
والاستخباراتي في التكتيك لكن في نهايه
المطاف الاستراتيجيات تختلف في حين ان
المستوى العسكري والامني بحاجه لكي يعيد
العقد الاجتماعي بحاجه لكي يعيد تلك الثقه
التي كسرت ما بينه وما بين الشارع
الاسرائيلي بدون ادنى شاك بنيامين نتنياهو
يبحث عن امر اخر يبحث عن صوره نصر تختلف
كليا يبحث عن صوره نصر تعزز من مكانته
السياسيه في داخل اسرائيل وبدون ادنى شك
او على الاقل تساعده في البقاء في والهروب
قضما في داخل كل هذا المشهد والان بعيدا
عن هذا كله ربما هنا كذلك تجدر الاشاره ان
في ظل كل هذا هذه الجبهات السبعه التي
يتحدث عنها الجميع هنالك جبهه ثامنه يجب
ان تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار هنالك صراع حقيقي
ما بين المستويين العسكري والسياسي وربما
حتى في داخل كل المستوى السياسي لم تشهده
اسرائيل في السابق نهائيا ولهذا السبب
يسال بجد هل اسرائيل جاهزه لان تخو ثمار
حرب كبيره في جبه الشماليه على سبيل
المثال يعني جبارين انوه فقط الى خبر عاجل
يتماشى مع الذي نتحدث عنه الان اذاعه الج
الجيش الاسرائيلي تتحدث عن اصابه جندي جرى
اطلاق صاروخ مضاد للدبابات على منطقه جبل
دوف على الحدود مع
لبنان نعم تحديدا يعني ربما عندما اشار
بنيامين نتنياهو الى 2006 لا اعلم كم كانت
اشارته صائبه في داخل الوعي الاجتماعي وال
وربما الذاكره الجماعيه الاسرائيليه لانه
تحديدا 2006 يشار اليها بالبنان بان هنالك
متلازمه
2006 التي عادت وكررت نفسها في عدوان 2014
وغيره من من الحروب التي خاضتها اسرائيل
منذ ذلك العام تحديدا في عام 2006 كما
يقول عامد رورو هو واحد الناقدون
العسكريون يقول بان اسرائيل خضت حربا
ابرزت فيها عضلاتها وقدرتها السلاح في
سلاح الجو بدون ادنى شك وربما يعني كانت
هنالك يعني كفاءه معينه في هذا المضمار
ولكن في ارض الميدان لم تخرج اسرائيل ولا
يمكن ان تقول انها خرجت بصوره نصر باي شكل
من الاشكال هذا هذا المشهد تكرر في عام
2014 وتحديدا الان كذلك ما يجري في داخل
القطاع يشار الى ذلك بانه تكرارا لكل هذه
المشهديه في نهايه المطاف بل اكثر من ذلك
هنالك الخوف يعني عندما يخرج يتسحق بريك
في قبل ثلاثه اعوام او اربعه اعوام وهو
احد
الجنرالات في الاحتياط ويقول بان كفاءه
جيش المشاه بدات تتدنى وذلك تحديدا اشار
اليه قبل اربعه سنوات عام
2006 ربما يعني كان الجيش ما زال في خضه
ما
زال يعني خرج من لبنان مبكرا فقط قبل ست
سنوات فبالتالي كان لديه تلك القدره
القتاليه لكن منذ عام 2000 تحديدا الجيش
يقود خدمات شرطيه ليس الا فالسؤال التي
الذي يتبادر الى الادهان منذ تلك اللحظه
هل الجيش قادر جيش اسرائيل جيش الاحتلال
قادر على ان يقود غمار حرب ميدانيه بمثل
هذا الثقل ام ان اسرائيل سوف تكرر ذلك
المشهد في قدراتها الجويه ليس الا
التدميريه وبالتالي تخرج بصوره وكانها
صوره تحاول من خلالها ان تخضع حزب الله
ليس الا فبالتالي هذا الامر كذلك يجب ان
يعيدنا الى الجبهه الثامنه في نهايه
المطاف الى اي مدى مستعد المستوى العسكري
الذي يحاول ان يرمم الصوره الان في في
داخل القطاع ان يخود غمار حرب جديده لا
يتوافق معها سياسيا مع الاهداف السياسيه
مع المستوى السياسي بل اكثر من ذلك يعني
ربما اليوم يخ
احد وزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ام سالم ويقول
في احد الاذاعات بان يعني يعني يصف ربما
يعني ربما هذه قمه الاهانه التي يتعرض
اليها رئيس هيئه الاركان في خضم وجوده في
هذا المنصب ويقول انه يتصرف كطفله بنت
ثلاث سنوات تلبس فستان وردي الى هذا المدى
وضع الاحتدام ما بين المشهدين السياسي
والعسكري في داخل اسرائيل اشكرك جزيل
الشكر ايهاب جبارين الكاتب المختص بالشؤون
الاسرائيليه حدثنا من po